The next step is to establish the key
performance indicators, or KPIs,
for your business.
This is an important step for
you to monitor and
understand how your company's
monetization plan is performing.
>> In successful companies like it does
it in Google, we love data in numbers.
The main reason is that with
regard to monetization,
numbers give a clear picture
on where you're standing.
Numbers will tell a real, true story,
no excuses or emotion here.
All you need to do is listen and act.
If the numbers show that you are not
going up and to the right, but
rather decline,
you need to take action fast.
However, you can only do it
if you have meaningful KPIs
that you are constantly measure.
We are not saying that all month will
be positive in terms of monetization.
In fact for
every startup there are many weeks
where you encounter major problems.
What distinguish
successful entrepreneurs,
is the way they deal with
those issues and problems.
>> So, how can you increase your odds
of building a sustainable business?
>> It's a fact that both luck and timing
play a role, but you can improve your
odds with good planning, and the agility
to maneuver when things change.